З початком бойових дій одночасно розпочалася ще одна війна - інформаційна, яка швидко вийшла за межі Росії та України.
У ній теж є ті, що зазнали поразки, кажуть медіаексперти.
І це - Володимир Путін і російська влада.
Від самого початку війни Україна перехопила ініціативу: щодня у соціальних мережах з'являються професійно зроблені відеоролики
про успіхи української армії, глядачі з європейських країн майже у прямому ефірі бачать катастрофічні наслідки дій Росії.
Але головне, кажуть експерти, це те, як поводиться український президент Володимир Зеленський. Він особисто і безпосередньо
звертається до глядачів як усередині, так і за межами України, підтримує бойовий дух українців і дуже ефективно розмовляє із союзниками
на Заході, виступаючи з промовами в іноземних парламентах та викликаючи масові симпатії жителів Європи,
які прагнуть допомогти Україні. Володимир Путін програє цю інформаційну війну і багато в чому
саме завдяки ролі Зеленського, вважають експерти.
Існує чудовий термін, який підходить для опису Зеленського. Він автентичний.
Це підкуповує, бо він безпосередньо звертається до медіа, каналів комунікації, соціальних мереж.
Не на користь Путіна грає те, що він належить до іншого покоління. Путін оточив себе радниками.
Питання комунікації він делегував. Автократи та диктатори зовсім не обов'язково добре розуміються на комунікаціях.
Вони можуть віддавати накази, делегувати, карати. Ця автентичність і безпосередність, з якою Зеленський обходиться з медіа -
не слід забувати, що він і до цього був професіоналом у цих питаннях, - цього у Путіна немає.
Це перевага Зеленського, яку не можна недооцінювати.
Зеленський, який своїми виступами перед громадянами і політиками інших країн активно завойовує симпатії всього світу,
був добре відомий росіянам ще до його обрання президентом.
Можливо, саме тому, міністр оборони РФ Сергій Шойгу
вимагає виключити його з "культурного порядку денного РФ",
тобто заборонити покази фільмів з його участю. У компанію із Зеленським міністр оборони РФ записав також
продюсера та режисера українського
походження Олександра Роднянського.
Поруч із Зеленським - ну, я гордий. Мені здається, Зеленський сьогодні дуже важлива людина просто для цілого світу.
Це такий приклад сміливої, відчайдушно сміливої людини, яка надихає свій народ до опору. Тому я гордий.
Щодо решти - я незалежний. На мою роботу це не вплине. Мені здається, у цій історії найголовніше те, що точно не міністрові оборони
і навіть не міністру культури визначати культурні повістки: що там має бути чи чого не повинно бути. Це зона вільної творчості.
Принаймні я вірю в це.
Російська пропагандистська машина теж намагається
активніше включитися в інформаційну війну.
Приміром, у Німеччині на початку цього тижня набуло розголосу відео, опубліковане в Telegram-каналі, який розповсюджує російську
пропаганду про війну проти України. У ньому йшлося
про підлітка, якого нібито побили до напівсмерті
на вокзалі за те, що він говорив російською. У німецькій поліції спростували це і висловили підозру, що йшлося про навмисно
створене "фейкове відео з метою розпалювання ненависті".
Медіаексперти визнають: Україна та команда Зеленського
куди краще знаються на природі соцмереж.
Президент Зеленський від початку був дуже автентичний
у соцмережах, вів інстаграм і таке інше.
Але це не єдине, звісно, бо сама природа соціальних платформ така, що там люди розповідають про людські історії.
І зараз ми бачимо, як ця лавина з людських історій захлеснула соціальні мережі Facebook, Інстаграм та інші. І люди, які постять, репостять,
розповідають історії про біженців, яким вони допомагають... Усе це вже неможливо подати як фейк, як це намагається зробити кремлівська
пропаганда. Люди вже бачать, вони вірять, вони знають,
що поряд з ними це відбувається
і тому вже неможливо від цього відмахнутися.
Вважається, що Україна часом навіть виграє й у російськомовному інформаційному просторі. Експерти називають важливим успіхом цієї
інформаційної війни проєкт "Ищи своих", адресований родичам загиблих та полонених російських солдатів. За їхніми словами,
людські історії, які неможливо спростувати,
набагато сильніші за кремлівську пропаганду.
Чи є шанс вплинути на людей у Росії, які роками
перебувають під сильним впливом пропаганди?
Безумовно, дуже складно достукатися, тому що пропаганда діє так, що вона абсолютно змінює спосіб мислення.
По суті, вона змінює картину світу. І захисний механізм психіки людини намагається все те, що не відповідає цій картині, відкинути і сказати,
що це фейк. Ми бачимо, що навіть сильні зв'язки з друзями чи родинні зв'язки не працюють у порівнянні з ось цією картиною світу,
яка створювалася протягом багатьох років. Тому це дуже-дуже складно.
Експерти зазначають: успіх української сторони в інформаційній війні забезпечує і те, що Україна веде війну за існування.
Багатьом людям - як на Заході, так і в російськомовному просторі - очевидно, хто є агресором, а хто жертвою.